as Memorial Day weekend approaches well
it's time of course to honor those who
made the ultimate sacrifice for our
country but it's usually also a time
where families and friends gather often
attending cookouts and taking a swim in
the pool Bianca Holman is live with the
reminders from the fire department how
you can have a very safe holiday if
that's in your plans hi Bianca
hey good morning cherry you know you see
someone struggling in the pool or what
looks to be drowning your first instinct
may be to jump in but if you're not a
strong swimmer yourself you could cause
more harm than necessary and so Fire
Department they recommend grabbing
something like this kind of like a pool
cleaner extend this out to the person
that is struggling to pull them on in
and that can be something that can be
life-saving for those who are struggling
while they're in the pool and if you
think about it we're round the pool all
year round we don't cover them or drain
them and so it stays full 12 months and
it's the worst call for a parent to make
who discovered their child in distress
a six person Fire Rescue team responds
to drowning calls some their to rescue
or treat the victim and others there to
control the situation 2019 the Southern
Nevada Health District has reported that
we've had 33 submersions and we've had
four fatalities in 2019 already in 2020
we have had submersions already - as
well it could take the rescue squad four
minutes to get to the scene so any form
of CPR is important once the person is
out of the water during the pandemic we
might not be able to have an in-person 8
hour Cpl CPR training however there are
online classes available and they also
tell me even if you start those chest
compressions and do something that can
be life-saving as well reporting live
from near timaya and Cheyenne Bianca
Holman 8 News now